howdy i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
report oh
i think this is our third administration
we've been doing this show for
going on 12 years anyway you know big
theme in 2020
2016 was dedolorization
deglobalization now it's all coming to a
head
stacy right we're going to talk about
dedolorization
it really started with when our guest
jim rickards who you know has many books
about currency wars
and things like that and he's also an
advisor to the cia on currency wars
and obama under uh his administration i
think it was in 2009 or 10
he weaponized the dollar openly and
aggressively on the world stage which is
swift
he uh he cut iran off from the swift
system and
at that time jim rickards had said to us
well you know he agreed with it because
he doesn't like iran
and he's a an iranian a hawk on iran but
he was like
the problem for us as america is that
you could really only use this once
because once you use it a second time or
a third time then people come up with
alternatives so here is our closest ally
of course is the eu eu draft
sets out plans to limit u.s dollar
reliance
a draft european commission policy paper
highlights the
european union's vulnerability to u.s
sanctions
and to financial risks the paper
highlights the eu's
vulnerability to u.s sanctions and to
financial risks
as the bloc looks to assert its
independence both economically and
financially i mean whether or not they
um
this at this time it has teeth you know
the fact is over the past few years
we've seen led by germany that it is it
is
building up this notion that the eu
needs to have
a their own financial settlement layer
beyond u.s sanctions it was germany that
led that and it was because of
the um trump bringing back in the
sanctions against iran
even though a lot of german companies
already had started
relationships with them under obama's
peace plan
yeah exactly so dedolorization d
deglobalization
so the deglobalization is also a big
factor here because heading into the
21st century we're heading into that
period of deglobalization that means
that
all of the globalization that went on
with the us dollars world reserve
currency is cracking apart it's breaking
apart
germany and europe you know they've got
energy reliance on countries
that the u.s that has decided
is not going not going to happen or
they're
shaky about or nervous about and and so
the european union is like look you know
we we're not going to
freeze to death you know we're we need
energy and so we're if it means
dedolorization and
developing parallel payment schemes and
parallel ways to
do business around the world outside of
the us dollar you know that's what we're
going to do
yeah they have the energy needs there
but they also have you know germany
is a really high tech producer
manufacturer
of goods and china imports a lot from
germany
so if they lose that market because
there are a lot of tensions between
china and the us
i mean obviously maybe that's going to
change under biden because he has a very
close relationship with china and he
helped get them into the wto that's just
the inevitability we've been covering
that for a while
now we're going to move to an another
story about this
global fiat system this global dollar
system this empire of debt
the last days of it right so that shows
the eu
looking for an alternative to the us
dollar shows that even the closest ally
and one well probably the biggest
trading block in the world
they are looking for an alternative
that's an end to the
ability to project power through your
dollar which you could freely print and
just
like a press of a button that's easy but
then we're moving to
another uh story about perpetual debt
and unfortunately this is from george
soros and i know a lot of like
conspiracy theorists will then jump in
the comments but nevertheless
he you know he is a guy who broke the
bank of england and he has interesting
things to say
because he's like at the top of this of
this fiat debt pyramid scheme these
these uh the hedge funds the private
equity
the guys who are like the fiat kings
that are ruling oh
you know that they they benefit from
governments
having perpetual debt so he's saying the
economic crisis is worse now than in
2008 there is only one way out let's
finance britain's budget deficit by
issuing perpetual bonds and taking
advantage of the fact that global
interest rates cannot fall any lower i
have long championed perpetual bonds
these are bonds that never have to be
repaid only the annual interest needs to
be paid to some this may sound like a
radical idea
yet perpetual bonds have been used for
centuries britain issued perpetual bonds
called consoles in 1752
and later used war bonds which also were
perpetual to finance the napoleonic wars
the u.s
issued consoles in the 1870s whether or
not those all collapse to nothing is
another thing but
yeah this perpetual bonds this utter
contempt for the future and future
generations that
is um you know more and more evident
this compression
of of the now you know trying to pull so
much
further into the future with argentina
they
issued the 100-year bond this is
perpetual bond so like 500 generations
from now we've already spent all
your wealth right soros is a good
financier but it's not necessarily
a good physicist and perpetual bonds
have the likelihood of success just as
you would if you're trying to create a
perpetual
motion machine right it it doesn't work
and perpetual bonds don't work because
it's just another name for quantitative
easing
it's just another name for debt
monetization it's just another name for
hyperinflation against real assets like
bitcoin and to some extent gold
so i'm surprised he would go down this
path of advocating
a failed policy unless it's kind of like
a double
fake right because he did break the bank
of england by destroying them
and forcing them out of the exchange
rate mechanism back in 1993
so you might be setting them up for
another huge billion dollar george soros
scam
i don't know why he's picking on the uk
suddenly uh but
you know it's a but if i were in the uk
i i
wouldn't go with this this way if memory
serves there's an allegory in australia
about magic pudding
it's about a pudding that you can eat it
eat it eat it and it never goes away
and i think the story ends tragically
but anyway stacy right so
um let's turn back to this with george
soros and what he's saying
is that he does point out qe is
essentially this he says although it is
generally unknown by the general public
the european central bank has
already introduced perpetual bonds ecb
has purchased massive quantities of
government bonds as part of its
quantitative easing program the experts
know that the ecb
has no choice but to own this debt in
perpetuity he's saying now the treasury
the uk
people themselves should be on the hook
for these perpetual bonds rather than
this
credit it's not actual money that these
central banks create they
can't create money they can only create
credit so they create credit
and they've built this giant bubble up
but now
we're seeing like with biden
administration mmt
universal basic income all these things
are now like trying to
turn all those credit facilities that
have enlarged this
wealth and income gap that they've had
perpetual qe now they want perpetual
money for the people they want perpetual
rent moratoriums they want permanent um
mortgage moratoriums they want to wipe
away all the debts of the student debts
so it's basically now become
you know that's what the democracy is
all about is who can default on their
debts and who's not allowed to
right remember the doomsday machine from
dr strangelove
dr strangelove was trying to get the war
cabinet to go down the path of accepting
the doomsday machine
uh this is a financial doomsday machine
it guarantees
global hyperinflationary collapse of all
fiat money
against bitcoin and gold so on one hand
perhaps he's got bitcoin's arrangement
syndrome uh soros has finally gone the
way of something like a paul krugman or
a nurio roubini where
his mind has turned to mush and he's
advocating
the doomsday machine okay fine i'll i'll
keep my bitcoin and i'll see you at uh
500 000 of bitcoin george i think it's
just
um you know that as we've covered the us
dollar turns 50.
since 1971 the whole world every single
country on earth has been on a u.s
dollar standard
that is a debt standard so we've had 50
years of
unmitigated growth of debt we're at the
endgame of it and this is the last bit
of plunder like get what you can
try to get whatever you can and that's
like it's just a natural thing to try to
come up
perpetual bond you've got to because
we've already extended maturities out
for
decades so uh what what comes next
well infinity per in in perpetuity
um eternal life like this is the
fountain
of youth that we've always been seeking
humans have always been seeking this a
fountain of youth and this is the
fountain of youth is like
okay your president may be an 80 year
old man
the people who run the economy may be 80
year old men but the fountain of youth
is to steal from
20 year olds 100 years down the road
that's you being
forever in your youthful age eldorado
i'll give you another literary analogy
here don quixote remember that was a
great story
the uh trying to go to war with a
windmill you're trying to
you're trying to go to war with nature
george you're trying to
stop the hyperinflationary fiat money
collapse with
a thimble against a tsunami good luck
george i'll see you at bitcoin 500
000. have a nice day soros is doing it
biden is doing it his administration is
doing it
the british government is doing it the
european union is doing it
the chinese are doing it everybody's
doing it they're trying to roll over
their debts
the fastest at this moment because if
that system's falling apart
whoever gets the most resources the most
assets the most hard money fastest
this is why you're seeing governments
around the world starting to mine
bitcoin this is what you're starting to
see
um erasing the debts of people like in
in new york city we see this new york
city tenants own over 1.1 billion
dollars in unpaid rent
that's just on the um the rent regulated
apartments in new york city they did a
survey and something like 20 percent of
them
have more than two months behind on
payments so
the federal government under biden
they're expected to you know in this 1.9
trillion dollar plan
uh the taxpayers are going to pay that
1.1 billion so they're going to uh
they're they're going to cover the cost
of all these unpaid rents so
of course that some of them they said
haven't paid in a year
so you're like well who's the trump that
some like eighty percent of the people
continue to pay their rent like who are
these trumps that paid their rent and
like could have
instead started accumulating assets
that's what you have to look at the
global economy as
it's like some chomps are getting are
are paying their rent and paying their
interest payments and paying the
the principal these other people are the
clever ones who are like
racking up debts for other people other
taxpayers
future generations to pay so that seems
to be the game
this is the micro quality of it and then
you have a macro
situation well it's not like there's no
consequences for all this in new york
city right naked man jumps on a subway
and
throws a guy down on the tracks then
gets his foot caught in the third rail
and electrocutes himself right there in
the middle of midtown
middle of the day right that's the
result of it's excessive money printing
that's
facilitating malinvestment and
facilitating
theft and narcissism that's what money
printing does and
that's the societal detriment that is
being caused
but people don't want to make that
equation they don't think oh my city is
falling apart
naked people wandering around
electrocuting themselves let's print
more money i don't get the connection
you will my friend think about it we're
gonna take a break
and when we come back more coming your
way
[Music]
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max keiser time now to get a part
two of our exclusive interview with
gerald celente of trendsjournal.com
gerald welcome back
oh thanks for having me on max we're
going to talk about
the thrucidity's trap with china the
great reset
the new brenton woods so let's talk
china
uh this will be the story of the next
decade we believe we begin
2021 with china in a similar position to
the united states after
world war ii remember after world war ii
america was the only economy standing
and it became the american century
here with the coronavirus it appears
that china
is the only economy standing the united
states and others
are ravaged by this and it's still
deteriorating
do you like that comparison and is that
an apt comparison
and what does that mean no you nailed it
one of our top trends for 2021.
china 2021 the 20th century was
the american century the 21st century
is going to be the chinese century the
business of america's war the business
of
china's business look they just passed
the defense budget last year
the largest one in america as the
nation's going down
and what is china doing it's of all the
gross domestic products of the major
nations
in 2020 china's the one the only one
that's going to have a positive
and you made it after world war ii i
look at america as
england after world war one and all of a
sudden
that pound went away and the dollar took
its place
i could see in the years ahead the yuan
being the major currency of the world
and the dollar becoming the pound
getting pounded down
so china's definitely taking over the
world right that's the
stacey herbert likes to talk about the
thucydides trap the uh when one empire
is
falling away and another one comes into
power we it goes back to
um the spartans and and the greeks uh
you know this is a long-standing
phenomenon in politics
you know trump slapped tariffs on
sanctions on china and its major
corporations especially in the high-tech
sector the u.s was fine when china was
stuck to
low value-added manufacturing but now
that it dominates high-tech
artificial intelligence space travel
we're getting angry
can the u.s force china to be a more
primitive economy gerald
absolutely not as i see it and when you
look at the trade deficit
the the uh trump trade war didn't do
anything the trade deficit against
china's continues to build
uh they keep exporting much more than
they're buying
and they're also developing a dual
circulation
policy in the sense that what they're
doing is
they know that exports are going to slow
down around the world as the greatest
depression worsens
so they're building up more of their
domestic economy
as other nations when the covenant war
began
started dumping money into the for the
citizens of slave landia
the chinese put the money more money
into building their infrastructure
and into small businesses so going
forward with all of this
the china is going to replace
america and they're not going to be able
to stop
it because the
political politicians of the united
states and europe sold the nation out
you look at china going into before they
were into the world trade organization
and you were mentioning before some of
the protests that we used to go on one
was the battle of seattle
people forgot that one the world trade
organization was meeting in seattle
some fifty thousand people peacefully
took to the streets
but they had those agents provocateurs
and perfect dressed in
black tough guys smashing windows and
burning a couple of cars
that's where the focus went on the
reason for the demonstrations was bill
clinton
bringing china into the world trade
organization
their gdp was like this for years
they come in in 2001
and it shoots straight up they gave the
manufacturers
gave china everything they were only
making junk over there
the european manufacturers the american
manufacturers
oh and when you open up here in china
you got to open up a company but you're
only going to own
49 of it and then they brought all the
tech over there
so now china got everything that they
want because the manufacturers from
heavy industry
to high tech sold out their countries
so they could get cheap labor to make
their stuff
bring it back mark up the price
and you could get a job in the service
sector industry and would get rid of all
that dirty manufacturing
that was the clinton administration oh
remember that what was that next sound
you hear
that nas what was that plate that nafta
oh yeah
it happened it's over began with nafta
ended with china if you recall at the
time joe biden of course who was in
government
was claiming that bringing china into
the world trade organization
would be meaningless essentially because
there's no way they could ever
manufacture anything of value
and that we should all the noise and all
the warnings from all the policy makers
and the economics
uh professors who are saying look this
is going to gut
u.s manufacturing he's biden said ignore
all that
it's meaningless and now he's sitting in
the white house apparently
so um you know let me get you a quick
take on something another
phrase that i came up with a while ago
again i appeal to your
wordsmithing i came up with this phrase
casino gulag to describe
what's happening in america in other
words we're all locked down and we're
forced to
gamble online to see if we can make a
protein pill
to survive another day and the reason
why this is relevant is that we've got a
company now called draftkings
that is essentially going public it's
gone public it's online sports betting
so online sports betting in an online
casino
which has been illegal for many years is
now legal
so we're going to develop uh
gamblaholics who are trying to
bet it's you know online to make a
dollar
to survive another day in the gulag
casino gulag what do you think you
nailed it perfectly
again they do this all the time when i
was a young guy was the assistant to the
secretary of the new york state senate
and they passed lotto they used to call
it play in the numbers back in the day
and we're breaking up with this they're
they're dude
these people are they're doing the
numbers and they're taking the money
from the people that can't afford it
or yeah so he's to break the chops of
people who used to play the numbers
but then the government got into it you
got to be in it to win it
i remember i was there when they passed
this it was okay for the government to
do the gambling
because then we could steal the money
from the people and the poorest people
are scratching off that stuff every time
and you nailed it again now they're
going to make they're making that legal
all over the place
so they could get tax revenue the same
reason why these slimy low-life
politicians
hey don't take a drag on that joint
you're going to get we're going to lock
you up
hey remember biden three strikes you're
out you have to get busted too many
times
with too much uh cannabis right oh yeah
but now we're going to make it legal
because we can make money on the taxes
what everybody has to get straight in
their mind
is that these politicians polytics
all they do is suck the life out of you
because they've never worked a day in
their life
they've been sucking off the public
their whole life
all they want to make sure is that they
get
tax money so they don't have to work and
they get their benefits
they get their their pensions they get
their salaries
while they close everybody else down you
mentioned the 70s there don't forget otb
off track betting right this was another
uh let's make
gambling legal uh and they became the
sleaziest uh
storefronts in manhattan uh so they
eventually had to close it down
as manhattan went disney fied and
everything went upscale because of all
that asset price and money printing
but now it's all back the 70s are back
gerald that's the good news and i fully
expect the bgs to have a revival
and i just got my leisure suit out of
storage my powder blue leisure suit and
i'm going to be just going all the way
down
to the off track betting and play the
lotto so this is great
now you have always said gerald that
currency wars lead to trade wars lead to
hot wars
we're at the trade war part of that
equation with china
are we on the verge of a hot war not
with china if there's a war with china
be the end of life on earth
look you know
the uh reality is the united states
hasn't won a war since world war
ii i forgot about grenada you know in
panama
and and you could sort you could see the
brilliance of the united states military
and their police
in what happened in washington on uh
january 6th so the united
oh how about what is it called the
afghan war what is
only going on now for 20 years no we get
an award with china it's over
it's over but the wars that i see that
we have to
start worrying about are going to start
breaking out in the middle east
as tensions keep rising around where
ethiopia
uganda congo libya
syria turkey again when all else fails
they take you to war
israel what's going on with netanyahu
running again and again and again
and being brought up on charges that he
can't still can't face and they're not
doing it
so i'm more concerned about that because
the united states knows that if there's
ever a war with china
it's the end of the world so let's dig a
little bit into
u.s dollar policy foreign policy in
saudi arabia
so the saudis in the u.s seem to be
loggerheads
and that their main supporter of the us
dollar that's part of the agreement the
petrol dollar from the early 70s you
know back to the 70s
is that the linchpin that if we pull
that out the dollar collapses
i would say so yes absolutely all right
let's try
that let me just hit you with another
question here the imf wants a brenton
woods and world economic forum is
calling for a great reset
what's your forecast and what these two
separate but related items mean
going on they got two major themes here
how do they connect
they connect because it's one big club
it's the
it's the bankster bandits and all
they're going to do is to
create more and more uh businesses and
opportunities
so the few could control everything and
again you see it with the people
how they it's okay if you just throw me
a couple of bucks
i'm i'm doing fine i don't have to go to
work
so the big the it's it's all coming and
i can see new currencies coming too
and i think that they know it they know
it
you're already seeing you heard just
christine lagarde
the former head of the international
mafia fed uh monetary fund
that's now the head of the european
central bank
coming out and warning against bitcoin
and you saw what happened as soon as she
said it boom
bitcoin prices after they rebounded
started going back down again
they know that the people know that this
money and what they're doing
is a total fraud they know it's
worthless
so my i believe they're going to come
out all of a sudden one day we're waking
up
we're doing away with that dirty cash
it's filthy
it's only been around forever but it's
going to get you sick so we're coming
out with digital
trash the dollar's gone the
the euro's gone we're coming up with a a
universal when you put the great reset
together
they'll come up with something new
that's worthless
and that'll get them out of their
so-called debt
that they don't have to pay and they're
going to try to destroy
gold silver and and crypto currencies
and and and just one thing that's not
a conspiracy theory wasn't it the jp
morgan chase gang
that had to pay 900 million dollars for
rigging the precious metals market
yeah and you know how they paid that
fine they rate more the precious metals
market
anyway gerald we gotta go great to talk
with you and have a great 2021 hopefully
we'll chat soon have a good day thanks
for being on kaiser report
and thanks for having me max all right
that's going to do it for this edition
of kaiser report with me max kaiser and
stacey herbert want to thank our guest
the legendary gerald celente
oh trendsjournal.com until next time bye
y'all
you